[Music]
hey will someone named Samuel Leeds and
in a moment right now me and Amelia are
gonna select one person to win four
thousand pounds credit to do any
training with us
so I mean geez four thousand that will
get you quite a bit right yeah you've
done some of the training with us yes so
to four thousand pounds I mean that can
get you on the deal finding Stravaganza
next month that can get you on the rent
to rent university that could get you on
the deal selling master class I mean wow
there's so many different programs that
can get you on and how we're gonna do
this then so we've been using a system
called Collegium and basically what you
guys have been doing is doing different
colleges to get as many entries as
possible so we're just gonna have a
quick look through and this is going to
be completely random right yeah
completely random okay are you gonna
pick it in a second we're just gonna
have a quick for you yeah we're gonna
have a quick look at some of the guys so
some people to get maximum entries they
held up a piece of paper that said
financial freedom challenge I love
seeing those posts thank you guys
you know I mean it could be anyone but
it gives you higher chances when you
engage more so so we're just gonna have
a little look at some of these just so
you can see them and see what everyone's
been posting so we're gonna maybe repost
it all actually free I protect mine I
would volunteer my time to protect the
environment and its inhabitants awesome
man and everyone who signed up to the
crash course thank you God yes crash
course all starts with a crash course
two days free at the minute it's free
and it's just mind-blowing ly good so
amazing so do you want to pick the
winner yeah yeah I felt a bit the winner
okay so all you have to do is click on
that and it will randomly pick okay so
it could be you who's it gonna be the
winner is just completely random right a
busy man
always another bottom up to play one
winner is Jake Sandler Jake
congratulations man
your life is about to change take your
life love change man serious you'll get
email automatically and will also will
try and give you a little call as well
from Cardiff how old is Jake oh my
goodness Jackson young Jake was born in
2001 what was I remember I was doing in
2001 that's like yeah 18 18 years old
Wow 18 years old Jake Sadler and he
follows us I want to call Jake man
message him and just don't tell anyone
just say what's your mobile number
that's okay so are you ready to site the
same yes this out okay
Oh seven nine hi Jake it's Amelia from M
Samuel Leeds team I've got Samuel here
with me it's just got a quick message
for you yeah what subject waiting bro
cool buddy listen just wanted to say
congratulations you won the 4,000 pound
training credit man
[Applause]
it's great man it's great man he just
means you it just means you're gonna be
able to do some training with us get
some knowledge get some knowledge and
become financially free so how you
figure we need to read sorry we're gonna
we're gonna redo the prize draw you
weren't excited enough hold on hold on
I'll call you back now anyway Matt I
would look forward to working with you
and as I once again masa Congrats
I'll get Amelia to follow up with you
with the details see you later
cool calm and collected he's right it's
pretty uh pretty good pretty good
it might really be student then he's
Matt I just woke up yeah hey man Jake
Sadler Jake's gonna look back on this
moment what day is it October the 4th
5th whatever it is 7th
Jason look back on this moment on the
7th and say damn I should have been more
excited than that that was the day that
changed my life man so anyway what about
sort of the folks that can we can we
give some more come everything we give
some VIP crash course tickets or
something away I want to give some more
thing goodies away because a lot of
people you know entered into this so
what about all the people that did the
picture yeah those guys are awesome what
can we do let's upgrade them VIP all you
guys how many the woman that it's a
cover toll there's a like hundreds now
right those guys
let me see so we've got um where their
names Victor Hana all those guys if your
honor if you can see yourself on the
screen
VIP free VIP ticket to the crash course
means you'll be sat right at the front
you get photographs with the speakers
skip the cues best experience work books
two days I look forward to that as well
guys man thank you so much it's been a
great challenge listen everyone's a
winner though because the crash course
is for it so if you've not booked on the
property investors crash course I'm
gonna put a link below in the
description on the house cost us tens of
thousands to put the events on with all
the lighting and the stage and the
audios and visuals and the music
why're we put it on for free why because
we are on an absolute mission to see as
many people as possible become
financially free through property I even
make my stuff you've done the training
your mom has done the training how's she
getting on she's loving it get on the
training man legs pillow I'll see you
there who's this hey yes it was me bro
dude you come in on the advanced
training yeah we've got you skipped man
4,000 pound credit I woulda thought you
didn't sound excited earlier dude man
I'll look for to get to know you I'll
get I'll get the guys to send you out a
confirmation in the next few hours all
right bless you bro thanks Jackie
awesome he thought it was a trick that's
what he wasn't excited
you